[Music]
hi mystery recap here today i'm going to
explain a science fiction film called
downsizing
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care
[Music]
the movie begins in advartsen institute
norway a group of scientists are
researching a procedure of some sort we
see dr jurgen and his colleague andreas
excitedly talk about an experiment that
has been successful the two hugging
excitement
cut to five years later andreas is
presenting their study to an auditorium
full of people in a convention center in
italy he has a box with himself that he
carefully sits on the podium he then
gives the audience a speech about the
negative effects of global warming and
scarcity of food and water it causes he
goes on to explain that their project
will not just reduce global warming but
also solve the problem of scarcity of
natural supplies
he says that this is the only practical
and humane remedy to mankind's gravest
problem he then proceeds to reveal what
is inside the box
the audience gasps when they see a tiny
dr jurgen in the box
he looks like any normal human being but
smaller in size
no one can believe their eyes
they stand up to get a better view of dr
jurgen dr jurgen asks everyone to take a
seat a tiny microphone stands in front
of him and he starts speaking he says
that five years ago he and his team
developed a procedure that reduces all
organic material to cellular level by a
ratio of
hundred forty four to one
using this process dr jurgen had turned
minuscule
the procedure was tested on a large
number of plants and animals and they
have found out that the procedure is
irreversible but has no side effects at
all
thirty-six volunteers joined dr jurgen's
team and they have been living life as a
small person ever since the procedure
only requires the removal of dental and
other prosthetics the person fully
recovers after an hour or two after
being turned small they then bring out
the 36 volunteers of the project who are
now small people
they have lived in the world's first
small colony for the past four years
they have also birthed a little baby
the audience clapped in admiration
this is the biggest discovery in history
the concept of downsizing is now
introduced
people from around the world watch the
television in shock as they broadcast
attractive advertisements about the
discovery they encourage everyone to go
miniscule to save the planet and for a
better life
paul saffernick is one of the viewers
he watches the advertisement in awe
he goes home to his sick mother she is
the only person in paul's life
she complains about the downsizing
program saying that the same energy must
be put into finding the cure for illness
it is now 10 years later paul's mother
has long passed on
paul now works as an occupational
therapist and is married to his wife
audrey safranick the couple is
struggling financially the two have to
relocate to a new home because of their
financial problems meanwhile the
downsizing program has become more and
more popular through the years
several minuscule colonies have been
established throughout the world
three percent of the world has gone
through downsizing and currently lives
in those colonies
one day the safranex go to their high
school reunion
there they meet their old friends dave
and carol johnson who have downsized
after the reunion they gather at a
friend's house where the johnsons boast
about it being the best decision they
have ever made in their life they now
live in a minuscule colony in new mexico
called the leisure land
when paul praises dave for doing so much
for the environment dave reveals that he
only did it for the money after
downsizing expenses dropped by 90
dave used to be broke in vegas before
they decided to downsize
now the two are going on a six months
trip to italy and living their best life
in a huge mansion
interested in the miniature life the
following day paul and audrey go to a
leisureland convention
there a downsized man explains to them
the benefits of being downsized
he shows them the house of his dreams
right in front of him the miniature
house opens to reveal a luxurious
interior a woman is inside the house who
boasts about her diamond jewelry that
cost her only 83 dollars
paul and audrey are fascinated by the
luxurious life of the miniatures they
then go to a viewing area where they
look over the leisureland
the colony is covered with nets to keep
away mosquitoes and harmful uv rays
the couple watch in awe and decide that
they too will downsize
they meet an agent who tells them that
in leisureland their 152 000 is 12
million dollars to live on
paul and audrey are stunned
later we see them selling their
belongings in a yard sale so that they
can sell everything and live as
miniatures later that day they meet at a
pub where their friends and family wish
them goodbye
later that night the two keep their
rings in a box to be brought to their
miniature house when they relocate
the following day they drive to the
leisureland convention where they will
undergo downsizing
however audrey seems to be doubtful of
the decision
the two are separated in the waiting
room
paul is taken for the procedure before
audrey they are told that they will meet
after the procedure when they are
already downsized at the beginning of
the procedure they shave paul's head and
eyebrows off as those cannot be
downsized then they change him into
hospital gowns and sedate him to trim
all the hair on his body they do the
same to several other men beside paul
since downsizing cannot be performed
with dental prosthetics they perform a
dental surgery on everyone and remove
the prosthetic teeth they are then taken
to the incubation hall where the
downsizers are kept naked the doors to
the hall close
after some time it opens and we see
everyone inside has been downsized
now they are scooped up gently with a
spatula and put into miniature beds then
they are handed down to small nurses
from the leisure land
their dental prosthetics are put back
into their cavity
finally the procedure is done and the
newly downsized people are sent to rest
when paul wakes up he is alone in the
waiting room a nurse greets him
she also gives him a huge cracker as a
gift he asks for audrey's whereabouts so
the nurse goes to look for her
she comes in with a phone sometime later
audrey speaks from the other end she
frantically tells paul that they shaved
her head and eyebrows then we see a bald
audrey with only one eyebrow at the
airport
paul is shocked as it turns out that
audrey ran away as they started shaving
her eyebrows she has decided to not
downsize at the very last moment the two
yell at each other through the phone
paul is now alone in the new city of
miniatures he is guided to his luxury
mansion but he now has to live there
alone
it is now a year later
paul has divorced audrey and settled
into a new apartment he had anticipated
an easy life but the divorce settlement
took away half of his assets
he currently works in a call center and
is dating a girl named kristen
one night they are in paul's room having
dinner when paul's upstairs neighbor
doosan comes in to inform him that he is
holding a party later kristen and paul
break up prompting him to attend
doosan's party
paul has the time of his life
he kisses a random girl and accepts a
pill from her the drug starts to take
paul over and he enjoys himself the
whole night the following morning he
wakes up under a table at dooson's
apartment the cleaning workers arrive
one of the workers who limps catches
paul's eyes since he is an occupational
therapist
he asks her to sit down and helps her
with her prosthetic legs paul recognizes
the worker is not glenn tran a
vietnamese political activist who was
jailed and downsized against her will
knock land's story was broadcasted
worldwide then but eventually it died
down
knockland takes paul to her neighborhood
to check on people there even though he
is a physical therapist and not a doctor
paul sees that the place she lives is in
extreme poverty even though they are
miniatures
there paul helps knock lane with her
prosthetic leg but accidentally breaks
it as a result of his screw-up knock lan
makes him do her cleaning job until her
new prosthetic legs arrive paul goes to
work with knock glenn every day and does
the cleaning for her they collect the
leftover food from the people they work
for and bring it back to knock land's
community to distribute it between the
poors paul sees the good in knocklan
even though she is suffering herself she
doesn't forget to help other people in
her community
one day knock land gets a cleaning job
at doosan's doosan is surprised to see
paul working as a cleaner and makes fun
of him paul informs him that he has to
do this for next six weeks to a month
seeing his friend suffer dusan decides
to help him
he offers paul a chance to get away by
joining him and his friend yours conrad
in going to norway where the first small
community was created
however noclan insists that she wants to
go to because she was called by the
doctor who started this all dr jurgen
the doctor too lives in the same colony
and wanted to meet knock land because of
her heroic protests in vietnam
the boys almost do not believe her but
they eventually leave for norway
cut to a few days later all of them are
traveling in a fjord indus yacht they
suddenly encounter dr jurgen and his
wife in their own yacht going to the
colony as well
knockland finally meets dr jurgen who
apologizes to her because his procedure
was used wrongfully on her
there the group is informed about the
methane release in antarctica that will
increase global warming by a vast
percentage this cannot be stopped and
because of mass overpopulation the human
race will eventually become extinct in
100 years the downsizing was made to
reduce the possibility to some extent
but only three percent of the whole
world is downsized
dr jurgen is devastated that his
creation was too late to save the world
the damage is irreversible
later knock lan and paul are together in
her cabin paul checks her legs
one thing leads to another and they end
up having sex
the following morning they finally reach
the first colony it is a tiny village
where people live in harmony they are
welcomed wholeheartedly
there the villagers have created a large
vault inside a mountain to insulate the
colony and preserve humanity in the
event of an extinction the whole village
along with dr jurgen and his wife
planned to go inside the vault the
following day inspired by dr jurgen's
words halto wants to go with the colony
he feels as though he was brought there
for a reason
so when knock asks him to come back with
her he denies
doosan and yours too are returning back
to their home
it is now the following day a few hours
before everyone migrates to the vault
knock asked paul if he had sex with her
because he pities her paul replies that
he really cares about her but the vault
gives his life a purpose
the time finally comes paul says his
farewell and goes into the vault while
the other three stand outside
however paul changes his mind midway he
likes not too much to leave for the
vault he comes back and hugs her
soon a vault store closes forever
the four of them return to leisureland
back there noc and paul live their lives
together while helping the people of
knox community living in slums
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching